[Music]
all right kay thank you over the past
few days las vegas fire and rescue has
responded to more than 50 heat related
calls
with so much excitement and activity
happening across the valley this weekend
doctors want to remind people about the
dangers heat like this can bring
bianca holman explains really not being
prepared
and not realizing that how quickly
you can run into trouble with
dehydration and heat exhaustion or
over the body overheating for those
limiting
but danger looms when extreme
temperatures last for several days
while you may think you're drinking
enough water dr warren volcker says you
could be at a deficit and not even know
it
i happen to have one right here so a
person should be drinking about six to
eight of those a day
um and and in men about eight
to ten bottles a day which equates to
about a gallon of water per day
to cool off many hit a splash pad or
pool
water cools your body temperature but
you should be cautious because you are
still sweating
losing fluid and drinking an alcoholic
beverage doesn't help
we see this all the time especially at
at uh you know the resorts
and and such and people that just aren't
used to
this they'll get very woozy very quickly
and they need fluid resuscitation very
quickly because the alcohol has
dehydrated them so much
their body temperature immediately goes
up when a person experiences heat
exhaustion heat stroke or dehydration
they may feel dizzy or tired other signs
include muscle pain or spasms
if this happens dr volker says give them
water and move them to a
cool place and if a person passes out
they need medical attention
immediately to avoid the direct sun you
may venture outdoors in the morning or
evening to ride your bike or walk the
dog
but remain on high alert we're still
getting quite a bit of radiation on our
bodies and our bodies will remain hotter
it does
seem cooler overall but it doesn't mean
that
you're not going to get into trouble as
well although anyone can be impacted by
hotter temperatures
certain populations are more vulnerable
dr volcker says pay attention to young
children
the elderly and those with chronic
medical conditions
these groups overheat faster bianca
holman
8 news now